a crack commando unit was sent to prison
by a military court for a crime they
didn't commit these men promptly escaped
sorry I had to cut that off the
a-team or better known as Charlie's
Angels with a sex change okay so me
personally I love the old 80s 18 TV show
naturally I was really looking forward
to this movie but from the trailer it
looked like the GI Joe of this summer
but was it it wasn't that bad a few
things were like there are some really
well shot moments in this movie it's
really cool to see their plan come
together yes just like the old 80's TV
show they're like MacGyver with guns and
grenades and impossible physics yes even
though it's fun to watch their plan come
together when it happens they defy three
little rules called physics logic and
possibility if I were to list off
everything that was pulled off in this
movie that would be absolutely
impossible to do this would be like a 20
minute long video but it was fun to
watch the happen the movies like
Mission Impossible meets smokin aces
until the last 15 minutes of the movie
when they just throw in some roland
emmerich was exploding I didn't
really know why and sometimes the action
sequences they were a bit shaky at times
it was like Tony Scott's cameraman got
palsy and then filmed all the action in
the a-team and there's really no mystery
in the movie I mean there was one scene
where they try to throw you a slight
curveball but for the most part you know
exactly who the douchebags are like from
the get-go I just would have liked a
moment or two where I was like who's
that guy old I didn't see that coming
did you see that comment wow did you see
that coming I didn't see that coming
just wanted to be like the fugitive with
an army arsenal you remember the
fugitive good movie had a plot twist
awesome but no not at all I mean for the
most part they were all good in their
roles I mean they're not gonna win
Oscars for him or anything but it was
almost like with face man that made him
like a cartoon exaggerated version of
him like when they're all in prison you
know that happens he's like living the
life he's living like in the Hilton I
just it was kind of ridiculous it's not
funny I mean I'll give it that it was
funny but the best part was Charlotte Oh
Charlotte Charlotte Oh cup um thickest
thickest from district 9 is howling mad
Murdock he was awesome he pretty much
made the movie for me he was great one
thing I noticed is that every guy in
this movie except for our for 18 members
they're the exception every other guy is
a douchebag in this movie like a really
eccentric fast-talking like used-car
salesman with a badge douchebag was like
everyone was like I want to be the grade
B house and they were the very great B
house so the best I can describe the
a-team is it's like a bad relationship
when you're in it you're like
it's good it's it's good I'm really
enjoying it it's really good it has its
ups you know maybe some downs but yeah
yeah it's fun but you stay and then when
you're out you're like holy I like
I enjoyed that movie like five minutes
ago like and now I would I go back no I
wouldn't do it I wouldn't watch it again
no bad relationship v18 so if you like
the concept of Mission Impossible and
smokin aces love child you'll probably
enjoy the a-team if not or you like
movies that are a little more you know
real you're gonna be really disappointed
those are the facts so that is my take
on the a-team so stay tuned for my
review of the two and a half hour movie
Karate Kid how could they make that two
and a half hours it's impossible but
they did